there's no reason to risk a man's life
here don't do this at home kid hey you
ready are you ready 3 2 1 action
[Music]
apparently we have some boxes full of
large ball that you can put yourself
behind them and then hit other ball it's
like a follower see how big these balls
really on let's say the bubble ball is
to hear all that alone so here we have a
giant ball problem requires a lot of air
is being plated solution moisture mark
air compressor baby we'll find out
I a question about whether it's going to
fit through the door
haha
real tight we're almost there one little
thing at a time
seems like I'm just surrounded by carbon
fiber we'll get you up no not everyday
that is to just like push your boxes
around like your hair you know sometimes
is like it's really hard to come up with
ideas for videos and you gotta like sit
down and really just hit your head
against the table several times before
you come up with something that's even
decent and then you got a risk on that
video idea I was envisioning Quinta's
gizmo duck writing a one-wheeled here
are a kid in the 90s you may have
watched the TV show called duck tales or
darkwing duck - excellent shows I think
they're even very making duck tales it
was a cartoon with bunch of ducks as
people there is a character from that
show who basically inherited what was
essentially Iron Man armor all the
character wants to do is just save
people and be a hero but he's constantly
struggling to even use the suit he
wasn't the intended wear of the costume
he accidentally said like the activation
phrase so the armor jumped on to him
whereas like it was meant for this other
scientist who actually knows how to use
a suit but instead this bumbling it
accountant he's like stop right there
I'm gonna fire missile at you no fires
like the opposite way yes he is no duck
does not have plague he has a wheel for
feet he's pretty much my spirit animal
he has like this hit piece and out of it
stick like two springs like shock
absorbers in a really nice mountain bike
gizmo duck moves entirely by writing
this wheel and I was thinking about how
would I do that
so obviously the first thing is you
dressed up like is mutt can you ride
around on the one wheel do you have this
issue and that you have legs your life
I mean for now I have legs someday I
won't because they'll just be a keep pay
to bite on a hard drive someday my final
florida data
let's do filling up some bigger flavor
all right now why do you need that thing
he's got enough lung power of those good
there's your video right there okay and
then finishing it you're passing out
that would be nice what would be really
nice is to get some really incredible
pot and smoke and then blow the hot air
into here so it's trapped no seriously
and it's to make a funny video take this
tool part everybody at the party would
you say a disc this is at least third
this is a thirty people hit oh my god ii
would be a wearable bomb and listen this
idea is a million dollar idea a wearable
bomb I'm telling you I've come up with
it I look [ __ ] genius what was the
name of the doctor again what was it was
my character's name after oak master Oh
more like professional token yeah
Oh Oh on top of the fact I think the
character is really cool and sets up a
lot of like dramatic story beats it's
the fact that he's writing a freakin
wheel as cool as the one wheel is you
can't be gizmo duck and write a one
wheel you have to be the one wheel the
warden rule so to do that there's a very
specific visual effects technique that I
would employ to make that happen and
that's essentially you paint out the
bottom half of the body and replace it
with a CG render of that contraption
I replaced the wheel are well what the
wheel delivers is realistic motion you
can't pretend to do this by like walking
around can you like I'm riding a one
riolu your heads gonna be bumping up the
couch you gotta be riding the one wheel
so I'll show you there's no reason to
risk a man's life here
I need to strap Elise around my arms or
else I think I'm gonna go flying good
just a little bit just a little bit this
will give us the best look don't do this
at home kid just don't go back number
Bethlehem hark we'll look at my thighs
all right three two one actually [ __ ]
you man [ __ ] you I've been waiting to do
that for long
[Music]
hey you we're back in action finally
celebrate we've decided to release a
brand new hat it's our name in katakana
which is really cool designed by the
talented kinder Tom we are releasing
this as of right now if you have missed
out on a chance to get a hat here's your
chance to get another one
it's an heather dark gray with yellow
print ooh check it out go to the store
and snag one because there's no time to
explain just just go there just quick
hit the book just hit the button hit the
button